طبعا حرب اوكرانيا هناك تساؤل هل هي سبب
ام نتيجه سؤال يطرحه كثيرون بشان التحولات
الجيوب السياسيه عالميا روسيا واشنطن
والصين والقاره الاوروبيه الكتله الشرقيه
في القاره الاوروبيه كانت دائما محور
السجان روسي غربي والحديث دوما عن
الضمانات لكن على عكس ماكينات على عكس ما
كانت تريده موسكوبات الوجود العسكري
للنيته اكثر زخما سياسه اعاده الانتشار
الامريكي تاثرت بهذه النقطه فعلى وقع
ارتدادات الحرب تحركت الكثير من القطعه
العسكريه والقوات الامريكيه من مكان الى
اخر والحديث ليس فقط عن اوروبا ولكن حتى
في المحيط الهادي تمدد النيته ولم يقتصر
تمدده على تعزيز الوجود العسكري بين راينا
تقدم السويد وفي لندن بطلب الانضمام الى
الحلف في اتساعا جديد للجبهه المانيا التي
كانت بعيده عن مظاهر العسكر منذ الحرب
العالميه الثانيه دخلت النادي مجددا
وافتتح الامر بميزانيه عسكري بلغت 100
مليار يورو لتسليح جيشها
شرقا نسجت روسيا علاقات اكثر قربا مع
الصين وتم الاعلان عن شراك استراتيجيه
وسعي للتعاون في التغلب على الظروف الصعبه
لكلى البلدين هذا التشنج الدولي انعكس على
كثير من الاتفاقيات التي كانت تسعى لضمان
السلم عالميا فمثلا جمدت موسكو مفاوضات
الرقابه على الاسلحه النوويه وانسحبت من
محادثات ستارت النوويه الجديده مع واشنطن